okay so a lot of stuff on the board
today the beginning of class and you'll
see why in a couple of minutes we're
going to finish up with tunt and like I
told you before I'm also doing this the
same material the same text in my ethics
class and so if you end up taking my
ethics class or the most other people's
ethics class you'll read this same text
again groundwork but I'm approaching it
in this class in terms of some some
other questions then we would look at it
in the ethics class and the other class
are mostly focused on you know what
should I do
this is about what should I do right
it's about this categorical imperative
and how do you apply it and what's right
what's wrong and all that but and this
is why it's nice to teach this in an
intro philosophy class this is also
about the metaphysics of the human
person nature of what it is to be a
human being
Conte is telling you about that I think
that for most of you that probably is a
surprise to hear that this is actually
about who you are this this treatise
that you read and the reason that would
be a surprise is because the problem
that most people have with cons is not
wrapping their head around the ideas
which are actually pretty
straightforward it's getting through all
this terminology all this jargon that he
uses you know synthetic analytic a
priori you know things like that or
categorical imperative all those sorts
of terms if we explain them they're
they're pretty easy to grasp but you
almost need a dictionary to go through
Conte and it's kind of funny this is
translated from German right because
khat was a German philosopher apparently
in the German it's even worse German
students when they're studying
Conte they often like to read the
English translations because they are
more clear than console original
writings so if you feel like you didn't
you know you're at sea with this and I
you know maybe only getting you know one
one point out of five and the rest of it
was kind of going past you that's okay
that's a natural thing to feel when
reading this text it's not like reading
played over it's you know it's two
people talking to each other or
something like that this is this is
difficult material so we're going to go
through that today but before we do that
I want to set the stage a little bit a
little bit of review tip so you've got a
question like this what should I do
that's part of ethics right horror could
be part of political philosophy if it
has to do with with what should we do as
a society but if it's you individually
what should you do well what should I do
or what should we do together that's a
matter of what we call ethics and that's
you know an important question so other
questions that might concern you more
directly Who am I and we're going to
explore that a little bit before we
would go into con two too deeply you can
go on from Who am I so whatever what
kind of thing am I
what kind of being and you know part of
the discovery of self that should be
going out of college is realizing that
you're more than you thought that you
were that's one good thing about people
I can't they reveal to you things that
you didn't you may have not known about
yourself Plato I hope did that for you
or maybe not I'm not sure how you would
do that but maybe he did and that's an
important part of your education is
figuring out not just who am i what am i
because that leads you to another thing
what about other people you know if you
know who you are part of that involves
knowing about it
doesn't it I mean you guys just went
home for Thanksgiving we talked about
this who did you visit you guys just
stayed in the hotel watch the game order
ordered in some turkey it depressing
Thanksgiving wasn't it who did you good
you visit your family and friends and
you who you are is firstly who they have
you you exist in relation to them and to
know something about you quite often
requires knowing something about them
every one of you is somebody's son or
daughter maybe you know unless you're
the only child you're your brother or
sister sometime down the line I'm
guessing most of you or any mothers and
fathers herself you have all sorts of
roles and right you know my mother is
not your monitor and then who my mother
was affected me in ways that made me who
I am
just as who your mother or your father
or even sometimes your close friends
they have made you in part who you are
not entirely not like you didn't have
any any role in it but you know they
they exercise where did you get your
notion of rank long from what you should
do they don't even get it in part from
your parents your own awful parents
right actually they could also give you
bad ideas about what you should do
I suppose but yeah all these things are
interrelated all these questions are
connected and so if we're exploring the
metaphysics of the human person what it
is to be a human being what are you made
of what what is in you we're exploring
all these questions and Conte is going
to separate out parts of the human being
from each other and you might not like
his solution to this but it but it's
certainly something worth we're thinking
about we're gonna get back to these
words like heteronomy and sensibility a
moment in a little while I just put them
up there cuz I don't want to forget that
myself but think about the human being
all right what does the human being
consistent we've looked at this a lot
this semester there's a part of you that
we call reason we saw this with Plato is
from Aristotle that artistas saw this
going all the way through the last thing
we saw was Descartes reason as one of
your faculties that's what keeps you as
a human being and not just a plain old
animal right you don't just have
instincts you can think things through
and you never will you have the Faculty
of choice and your will is different
than a dog's middle or so we think it
should be NZ's will it's a free will so
the will of a rational creature and that
makes you different you can actually
think about you can you know the dog
doesn't you ask yourself what should I
do
I've been a moral dilemma should I do
yes first would I do that the dog just
you know has a bunch of different things
impinging on it and then whatever ends
up being the strongest desire or
motivation wins so the animals do some
problem-solving like you know you can
take a raccoon and they can't get to the
food right away and I can figure out it
needs to go around and occupy apparently
can act
they're smart enough they can actually
watch a human being unscrew a lid take
you know a jar that's got food in it and
they will figure out that they need to
unscrew that lid which is pretty smart
but that's not yet the same thing as
having a free will where you worry about
are you doing the right thing are you on
the right track but do I've never he
asks it's all I'm a good dog human
beings you know we tell them you're a
good dog you're a bad dog
and we usually tie that with you're a
good dog you get a cookie you're a bad
dog here's the newspaper you know
whatever else you used to punish the
door but that's not like a human being
we start from that but very quickly we
move beyond that we will that is
actually able to change itself that
makes you special and that's probably
the most valuable part of you and then
you have all these what we talked about
as inclinations and desires right and
you know counters not staying at your
desires your pan or your inclination
he's not saying it's bad that you enjoy
I may be like chocolate anybody doesn't
like chocolate it's kind of rare but
there are some people that's an
inclination how did you know that you
like chocolate in the first place you
tried it so something in the world you
came across probably as probably before
you remember right the first time they
can have it you were probably toddler
and somebody at a Christmas party or
something said here try this chocolate
bar you try it in here you wanted more
and more right how many of you when you
were kids tried your mom or dad's or
uncle's beer or wine or mixed drink or
something like that and you didn't like
it right it's good thing you did because
you're not supposed to be drinking with
you
some kids actually do like the taste of
that but then they'd really want to keep
them away from all sorts of things and
then this is with your inclinations -
how many of you still like Jonathan
follow me right I can't ask you actually
how many of you like to taste a beer or
wine or anything like that because of
course you're all underage so promoting
drinking but you can imagine yourself in
a case where you might you might have a
beer or something like that how many of
you have found that your tastes how many
of you would have found down the line
that your tastes have changed I know I
found that out and I was kind of
surprised because I remember how awful
my dad's beer when I was like you know
six years old tastes horrible but now my
tastes have changed those that's
inclinations it's kind of I put this
quote up here and I'm gonna race this in
a couple of minutes to make room for
other stuff this guy Bree yes sir
sadly Ron said tell me what you eat and
I will tell you who you are because what
we eat is an important part of our life
do you subsist on junk food that's a
certain kind of lifestyle yeah
do you spend time you know carefully
picking out the menu items and then
finding the best ingredients and then
cooking them Wow because you may
actually put some effort into that
that's a different kind of lifestyle
isn't it some of you talked about over
Thanksgiving helping out with the
cooking right why do we turkey and hand
together and stuffing green bean
casserole and that sweet potato thing
with the marshmallows that people make
why do we have all that that stuff why
don't we just order pizza yeah and yeah
you know that's perfectly water isn't it
would you feel bad if you got home
your first time back from college and
your parents it said well you know what
we did all that Thanksgiving stuff for
years and here is a good kids because
you know I know that you liked it but
you know it's just too much bother now
we're not going to do that anymore we're
just gonna order Chinese how would you
feel what's up there's the really that's
that's kind of strong response I suppose
I probably would but who are you to
change these traditions may you feel
disappointed at the very least right and
then it has to do with who you are what
else do you guys you know you let me
just think about all the things involved
the world that we know everyone is
wearing clothes which is good because
otherwise you'd not only be in trouble
but you'd be cold right why did you pick
up the stuff that you got
why don't you dress like this shouldn't
you all be you know dressed up in a suit
and tie for class
some schools they they do that but not
embarrass you guys are dressed the way
college students right some are more
dressed up somewhere some are less rest
stop yeah think about the clothes that
you have in your pocket how would you
feel somebody came in and took all those
away and issued you a bunch of new
clothes they don't have to be uniforms
they could be really nice clothes like
well we've got this pant rhinology okay
right do they do they make clothes at
all or is just designer I don't know
let's say cuz we can make up anything we
want they suddenly got into the fashion
industry whole hog and they came up with
a really great line of clothing and
while you were sleeping at night in your
dorm they came in and they took all of
your old stuff and they burned it all
because they said this is this is
terrible you can't be trust like this
and they give you some really
fashionable high-end durable comfortable
clothes how would you feel
confused probably annoyed yeah yeah you
know your tastes are your taste and
they're gonna change over time too right
you're not going to be wearing the same
thing ten years from now you're wearing
right now probably with with men's suits
you can wear them for a very long time
go to the men's fashion
fancy stuff doesn't change very much but
it does for the other stuff and that is
perfectly you are going to go that's
part of your inclinations and desires
and that's part of the world that you
experience who you like to spend time
with what kind of activities you involve
yourself in what you consider to be
important what you spend your time on in
your day I mean every one of you has
exactly the same amount of time to
figure out what to do it as everybody
else we're all equal in that respect you
got 24 hours you dispose of it how you
like all of that is at least in some
respect a matter of your desires and
inclinations and those motivate your
will to do things and when it comes down
to con stuff that what we talked about
earlier the objects of your desire
inclination those affect your will they
say you should do this you shouldn't do
that if you want this then you should do
this instead this is something worth
having go pursue it and then you
actually choose to do that on some level
you're not consciously aware all the
time of choosing like that but at every
moment that you actually do something
you choose it and you're motivated by
objects of desire so when you went to
the cafeteria and you you know what did
you have for lunch today
I don't know what they had because I
didn't whatever they have
nothing memorable a it looks like so
then if the main entree isn't good where
do you know sandwiches or pasta or and
then when you get the pasta station and
if you just go to the pasta station you
don't say anything they look at you like
you're like you're stupider than what do
you want what kind of pasta and you have
to choose you want the vodka sauce do
you want the alfredo sauce do you want
the meat sauce you know those are all
true good right
those all have to do with what it is
that you want at the time and things
from the outside motivate you to make
those choices sometimes it feels like
it's just you know within you and maybe
there are some things like that and then
there's another impulse
we're not impulse but rather motive
that's duty doing what it is that you
want to do but you should do and fork on
these are worlds apart from each other
the right thing to do is at least for
Kant for most of us not what's actually
going to make us feel good it could if
all of your desires and inclinations are
perfectly lined up and exactly the way
they ought to be then doing the right
thing would naturally make you feel good
but do you do the right thing and we
talked about this last time you do the
right thing because it's the right thing
what are you doing because of that good
feeling you get from it I mean it's
better that you do the right thing and
get a good feeling from
and do the wrong thing because you get a
good feeling right let's say we talk
about eating people up it's better that
when you're angry with somebody you
don't go after them and beat them up and
that you feel okay about that afterwards
and that you sort of congratulate
yourself and say that was really close I
I feel good about myself I feel proud
that I kept my temper under control
that's better than to go and beat the
person off which feels good for a lot of
people right that's why they do it
one is against duty and one would be in
accordance with duty but it still
wouldn't be of duty it would be better
for somebody like on to not go and beat
somebody up even if it goes against what
you feel hope desire because it's the
right thing just because it's the right
thing no other no other moment anytime
for somebody like on anytime that you
get some sort of good feeling out of it
you should be suspicious that you're
only doing it to get that good feeling I
think about you know christmas is coming
soon right when we do at Christmastime
well sing carols and eat cookies what's
what's the biggest what's the big
presents right and why do we give
presents if you could have a lot of
different motives for that fig jam
giving presents is a good thing it's
benevolence it's doing good to another
person do you do it because you want to
get in with that person some people get
the presents that way all right if you'd
like to be friends with this person so
you give them a nice present I'm gonna
sleep with this person give them a nice
present should give your boss the
present don't work because you want to
you know get in with them a little bit
people do that my family people actually
tip the mailman and the garbage man at
Christmas
because that's you know sort of it I
guess a Chicago custom why do you tip up
is it because you're just you know so
happy with their service and goodwill
for all mankind no that's because we
want to make sure that they're gonna
give you a good service the rest of the
year so they'll remember you right
why else could you give presents or do
good things to other people you love
them you want them to be happy
now you're getting closer to something
that could be about duty do you want
other people to be I think all of you do
do you want other people to be happy
because that makes you happy or do you
want them to be happy because that's
good for that that's something we're
thinking of incarnate isms by the way
constant savings we had to be happier to
make other people happy or anything like
that it's not in the world but it's not
yet moral if you're only doing it
because it makes you feel happy and this
is again the one reason I'm not a
conscience because I think that it is in
fact good for me to want to make say my
children happy by giving them presents
that make them happy I think that's a
good thing doesn't Kahn thinks it's not
good or bad it's just some sort of
motivation coming from the outside this
is what he means when he talks about
heteronomy it means literally another
law walk coming from the outside of
something determining the will that is
not purely on the will purely of dude
so how do we wrap our heads around this
and this is where can't talk about what
he calls in comparators
you can think of yourself a couple
different ways as a human being when it
comes to your reaction for anything that
you do I can always ask you why did you
do that and you can always give you some
sort of answer and you know let's let's
set aside the fact that you could lie or
you know be deluded about your answer or
anything like that you could screw with
me and say well because you know the
president is coming next week and that's
why I came to class which would be a
crazy response let's assume you're
getting a genuine response if they ask
you why did you do something you could
give me an answer that covers just that
situation right and I could say to you
then why do you do that sort of thing
then what would you do you would give me
an answer that covers more situations
well that's the kind of person I am
or I think this is an important thing to
do so let's who's giving presents how
many of you're going to give people
presents as Christmas we've actually
well not we I should say me I didn't do
that most of the shopping I'm fortunate
enough to have a partner who takes care
of most yeah we've already got most of
our presents apply how many of you
and then the rest of you are going to be
faced with a question of what are you
gonna do you're gonna get some
complaints right you're gonna make a
choice some of you have already made
that choice you're already done why are
you gonna get those people those
presents let's just pick like one person
how many of you didn't your mom will
present I can come on birthing because
my my adoptive mom is actually passed
away because it's okay why are you
getting your mama president she's
probably fine without all right does she
need a present from you
world's not gonna add a few dollars
there's no like internal necessity you
know that requires that you must
purchase a or make the present for your
mom
why are you getting
yeah so it's okay so there's a
give-and-take in reciprocity and yeah
because she is your mom okay so if
you're going to get so many presents
yeah that leaves the door open I'm not
getting anybody any presents should be
your people that you're close to and you
can give them presents because you're
close to them right well that's kind of
a rule you can't even look at that as an
individual case and then you can also
look at that as a rule
anybody who I'm close to what about next
Christmas are you close to that person
you should buy them of presents you're
not close to them don't buy them a
present
that's what you would call in some
respect and imperative and how many of
you studied foreign languages French
Spanish German okay so you're you guys
are familiar with this term right
because there's the imperative mood in
French or in Spanish or German or what
else did you guys study wow that's
impressive
do they have been parented more as well
an imperative means the the tents in
which you are not the tents the mood in
which you tell somebody what to do so if
I say you know this card is on the table
that's that's what we call the
indicative and if I say the cards on the
table go get it that's imperative that's
that's telling you what to do give your
mom a present that's an imperative when
you're in a situation where somebody's
close to you and it's Christmastime
give them a present that's another
imperative see these these covered
general situations as well as particular
situations we're talking about right and
wrong we're dealing with these big
general facts so
thou shalt not kill that's an imperative
saying don't go ahead and kill anybody
it's a little difficult to figure out
exactly how to fit self-defense or
things like that in there but you know
you get the general idea
now imperatives can be done a couple
different ways concepts and he talks
about three different kinds of little
different characters there's imperatives
of skill so for instance let's take some
sports things right you're gonna have to
look anyone else in here an athlete for
marys what do you play oh you roll okay
run track okay okay so we have four
different types of activities each one
of them you can be good at or bad right
what makes a good or bad it how can you
tell if somebody's rolling right okay
and then there's probably a bad result
so let's say they're actually you're
everybody's growing this way but this
person is growing the other way that's
that's not going very well
there are imperatives that cover them
how do you know what a ball is coming to
you how do you know what to do okay and
how do you know that you have to make
these particular motions in order to
catch it it's become more or less
unconscious all right said rolling to
right you don't think about every single
stroke but all these things are governed
by what we call them here is a skill if
you want to produce this result that do
this then then do this as an imperative
part that's saying do this so you're
sitting there in the boat and somebody
screwing up and they're there say out of
rhythm
you say get with the rhythm you're
giving them a command
and if they asked you well why should I
do that
you you might just look at them as if
they're stupid because they're involved
in your activity but what's it but you
could also say well look you're you're
not helping the activity you're actually
hindering it and then they might say oh
I don't care about that they said well
then you shouldn't be here on the boat
should you because you're part of this
activity if you want to be part of the
team then this is what you have to do so
do it but they could always say I don't
really want to be part of the team it's
what we call a hypothetical imperative
if you really do want this then you have
to do this medicine is like that too
we're building a houses like that I like
to say which relatives it isn't mine
most of them do an incredibly great work
when it comes to building because I come
from a family of trades people and some
are Mason's and some are contractors
some are carpenters and some of them
just do incredible work my uncle drywall
for years and years now he's an iron
worker I do have some relatives that
even like the white switches you go to
their place the light switches are off
kilter and you walk in and you you know
you've all seen dr. Seuss books right
where everything's at weird angles and
you look at it you're like who put damn
in didn't you didn't you actually want
things to be level and look right they
could say I don't care I mean for for a
lot of us they would sort of offend us
and you look at anybody like you know
what kind of you know and then you
substitute a lot of squares person put
in put in there but you know impaired is
a skill they only matter if you want to
produce a certain effect and they cover
all sorts of things and you know what
they could be good or they could be bad
if you want to kill a person you can get
books on how to do that you know and you
can get books on all different ways to
do it how to stab them you know how to
poison people
yeah I'm not suggesting anybody do this
because that would be that would be bad
right but if that's the end that you
want to produce you can find out
information actually now on the internet
you can find out any sort of bad thing
you want to do I'm willing to bet
there's a site out there that tells you
how to do it well so no there's also we
call prudence and when it comes to a
period as a skill you and I want
different things and each one of us
wants different things so let's think
about cooking for example all of you
like spaghetti spaghetti meatballs
anybody here doesn't like it how much
garlic should you put
some people don't like garlic in their
meatballs anybody who doesn't how many
would you would say you know if you've
got like a pound of meat two cloves of
garlic this time about right now some of
us like more garlic like I might put
four cloves of garlic and a lot of
pepper a lot personally that might be
too spicy for you right you might not
like that you should put four cloves of
garlic in for each pound of meat that's
an imperative but you don't share the
fifth part if you like things that way
then do it this way when it comes to
prudence what is it that we all do in
fact desire in general the biggest
general way of time is there anything
that all of us do want Aristotle talks
agreed for it was eudaimonia but we call
it you know we all do desire happiness
and that looks a bit different for for
us right I mean for me happiness it's
probably going to be somewhat different
at 40 years old than it is for you at 20
but there are some general things share
and you can take it for granted that
everybody does want happiness everybody
wants their desires and inclinations
satisfied that's part of what it means
to be being imperatives of prudence are
our imperatives about how you do that so
if you want to be happy should you spend
all your money on lottery tickets what
do you think good investment or bad
investment what do you say how many to
say it's a good investment not a single
one how many think it's a bad investment
some people are unsure because you could
win that big one right so why why is it
it wasn't a bad idea to spend all your
money on lottery tickets for slot
machines or video poker or pick whatever
game of chance you like
so you guys know that that's not good to
do spend all your money on the lottery
ticket if you're not sure why yeah it
actually says on the back of a ticket
that they were required by law each
ticket generally pays out this much and
it's usually anywhere from like 55 cents
up down to 30 cents so that means if you
invest a dollar you're probably getting
55 cents back so if you invest $100
expect to get about 55 bucks even less
if you then reinvest your winnings into
more lottery tickets okay so the nice to
work at a gas station where let's hold
scratch off lottery tickets I'd see
people come in with it 100 bucks 500
bucks for the ticket scratch them all
off they won their 50 bucks turn that
into 25 bucks turn that into 12 bucks
and then pretty soon they're there you
know it's all go on and then they're mad
because they thought they were gonna win
big well you know you know that that's
not a prudent thing to do cuz you can
think this this out right if you want to
if wealth is important to you is wealth
important to you I hope it is because
you're going to need it in order to be
happy if wealth is important to you then
you should do things that will build
your wealth buying lottery tickets is
probably not in that class of things
what would be something that you should
do yeah you're not gonna have any source
of wealth if you don't have a job what's
a much needed waiting for somebody to
die so you can inherit
it's true what they say about you marry
money you're earning well those are all
Maxim's improvements those all have to
do with satisfying your desires and
inclinations conjugant is not saying
it's a bad thing but those are
conditional do you want this you know do
you want the same things that I do
exactly I doubt that having a collection
as extensive a collection as possible
1980s heavy metal music - glam metal is
a actually high on your list of things
that make you happy you might be
interested you're the only person I know
in all my classes who actually had any
sort of positive response to that but
that actually does make me happy I
suspect all of you have music
collections right in iTunes is that what
you guys use and your music collection
you add to every so often happiness for
you looks somewhat different than it
does for me and it looks different for
each one of you these Maxim's are these
these imperatives of prudence are not
comprehensive enough they don't actually
extend to all of us if you do desire
this then you want to do the thing that
leads to that but that presupposes that
you actually do desire the like this or
that that's the thing that you ought to
be doing that's what we're trying to
figure out right another thing is
possible we call imperatives of morality
these are not conditioned these are what
we call categorical categorical applies
to everybody so they're not things like
well if you don't want to get in trouble
don't kill people maybe you like to get
in trouble right
maybe happiness for you actually
includes being behind bars or being on
the run from the law but to say you
shouldn't kill people or you should you
know don't kill
that's unconditioned you're not putting
any well if this then this you're not
putting any provision look this applies
across the board so that's the kind of
thing that kind considers moral now how
can we figure these these things that
how can we decide what a categorical
imperative this time q3 formulation so
those those are on that worksheet that I
put in either for you and we're just
going to look at two of them so account
gives us two formulations right and the
first one is is very long and always on
the maximum that your your you could
will at the same time in the universal
walk we're going to boil it down so it
would be something like this
so you can make yourself all sorts of
rules right here's an example of one
that has to do with killing when I feel
threatened and my life seems to be in
danger I will kill whoever in dangers me
that's a rule that you could act out
right you would be kind of a dangerous
person you're working on because anytime
you feel threatened you start killing
people there are people who live like
that how do you know that that's the
wrong thing to do well can you will have
to be the universal lock and you say
that everybody should do that imagine to
yourself a world in which everybody when
they feel threatened they start killing
people what would that look like how
many people would be left I mean was it
start out with like you know 7 billion
like what we got right now
now imagine everybody has that mindset
everybody follows that rule
does it make sense to try to say yeah
that's what everybody should do what is
it that's looking at consequences
there's actually sort of a contradiction
built into the very notion of well
whenever I feel like I go off to
whatever my inclinations tell me to kill
somebody
I kill them damn
it doesn't work let's use one of the
examples that confident also uses let's
think about one that has to do with your
talents you guys are in school and some
of you are one X how many of you are in
other sorts of activities if clubs I
suppose right oh yeah yeah and to do
that is it actually you're not only
practicing your part you're actually
learning how to work with other people
and making music which is very complex
activity and you're developing yourself
and doing that you're developing what
kind of calls your your talents and your
faculties what else could you be doing
instead of that we think about the
temptations of college life
how do people end up dropping out what
do they end up doing instead of
what's up yeah party English basically
means drinking or using drugs random or
it may be docile random sexual
encounters and I'm staying up late
I think she's doing random activities
you know because that's that's kind of
fun what other things can get you in
trouble I mean if you spend all your
time partying human age to college
that's pretty clear are there other ways
that you can work quietly as you can or
anything the second most common way
temptation
what oh yeah
yeah I suppose that that would be bad
and then you wait but then what are you
doing but you're not sleeping and you're
actually up instead of going to class
what sort of activities I mean some
people sleep in because they're off
weight you know partying
there's another activity that can really
easily lead to losing sense of time I
helped me study because laughs and
you're quite conscious of how much time
you're putting and studying right what
else nobody here plays games Xbox or
Playstation nobody here doesn't really
yeah and it's easy actually and once you
start playing those for the games the
physiology of your brain you're focused
on that you can you can drop a couple
hours just like that playing again
they're designed to make you do that the
more and more rich in their their
stimulation like back you know it's
basically something like that and we
consume in my generation we could lose
half a day playing the Atari which was
you know awful yeah as far as computers
go the stuff that they have now you know
the incredibly long story lines you can
easily lose yourself in that that would
be the example that'd be that'd be an
example of what kind calls just letting
things go not not cultivating your
talents if you're playing games all the
time you're you're developing it your
thumb movements very well and you know
that you know right right up left AC
means do this sort of move but does that
help you on the real world does that
change who you who you are for the
better I mean it might get you something
you know
some reputation among other people that
are into that game but that's about it
right some people lose themselves and
playing games like the Simmons it's been
hours on and they don't cultivate their
own talents that way I suppose the other
thing would be social networking the
social networking could actually be
developing who you are as a person
couldn't it you're working on your
social skills you're actually writing if
you're doing social networking but
granted a lot of people don't write well
but then often times people will make
fun of them if they don't then you might
learn you know the word spelled this way
and that's actually developing your
talents so could you will that you're
presented with a question should I
develop myself or not should I go to
college and just you know hang out and
have a good time or should I actually
apply myself could you imagine a world
in which people didn't apply themselves
you couldn't write I mean imagine the
technology that we have now couldn't we
have a world in which none of us
actually have to do much of anything and
we just enjoy ourselves all day long we
could do that Khan says you can't
actually will it you know why because
you wouldn't be developing who you are
as a human being and you would feel that
there's something missing in your life
what you are is rational being and
developing your rational faculties
developing your reason and your will
that's part of your purpose here and so
it's a will that don't develop your
reason in your will would be to go
against your own will in a way that
sounds a little convoluted right let me
say that again to to will to choose not
to develop your reason and your will
would be actually to go against the
nature your well it would be to live a
life that in some ways is less than
human less than distinctively human like
whatever salsa with you know the life of
just pure enjoyment is slavish another
formulation of the categorical
imperative that I think it's easier for
you guys to relate to immediately is the
one where it says this is a second and
so that you treat humanity in yourself
and in others always is an end and never
as a means alone so let's boil this down
treat yourself and others or if you
wanted to simplify this even more don't
use people
if the those course of action that
you're doing is just using somebody it's
not recognizing over they are it's not
treating them as equal to you it's not
treating them as equally valuable that
it's wrong that's not good if it can in
fact recognize them and perhaps you can
elevate them make more of them and prove
them that it's moral that it's good so
think about relationships
what are the reasons people get into
relationships mmm I think you know it
should be very realistic here I'm not
talking about necessarily your
relationships what do you know that
people do human beings why do people who
get involved with each other as friends
or lovers
there are motives
oh let's think about this situation why
are we all here in this room I'm here
because I'm getting paid you're here to
learn you could have multiple one of
those I like actually learning by seeing
what you guys write then seeing the
questions that you ask and I enjoy
talking about this stuff and sharing the
great philosophers their thoughts with
you because there's always like one or
two students that get turned on and
started studying audacity because of it
I like that but you know frankly my main
motivation for being us but I'm getting
paid otherwise you know I could be doing
this in a bargain or you can't pay so
there's no financial incentive and you
guys are here to learn but also satisfy
a credit get a degree keep mom and dad
off your back yeah
sure that's okay you could ask about me
as your instructor am i treating you
just as a means to an end if I'm just
here to make money how would I be
treating
let's say I wanted to you know we have
these evaluations coming up and you know
you guys are gonna rape me you're gonna
actually get you're gonna give me a
grade you know ABCD if it's actually one
two three four five but maybe in order
to get you know good evaluations I
should like give everybody a name make
sure that you you have a name right now
yeah but you know that you're gonna get
one so that you'll give me a really good
rating too that might make a lot of
people happy my desires and inclinations
but the question you ask about morality
how would I be treating what I be
treating you as an end as somebody
valuable if I if I don't actually grade
you fairly and I just you know give
everybody a gold star or what I have to
be just treating you as a means to net
what do you think it might feel okay to
while you're doing it but then later on
you feel bad about it yeah you would
feel kind of used what if I came in here
just because I'd like to talk a lot and
be up on stage you know be the big
philosopher and you guys are my buddies
would I be treating it any less as a
means to an end than if I'm just doing
it for money it still just be a means to
an end wouldn't you
what could I be doing that with this
class because I am treating you as a
means you know that right I am making
money off of being here in this class
with you not getting paid for student or
anything like that but I'm getting paid
to be here
so you I am treating you as a means if
I'm not just treating you as a means how
would you know that what do you do you
feel that I'm just treating is a means
or you know have I given you that that
sort of approach
No why not what else is going on here
that that indicates to you that you're
more than just a means that's important
because you may in fact have some
professors I hope none here at Marist
but you could have someone who just read
news it means you could have bosses who
just treated as a tool for their desires
and you could even have a you know
boyfriend/girlfriend husband/wife
who would just treats you as a means to
that so you really want to know what it
looks like when somebody doesn't just
treat you as a means how do you know
somebody actually sees you as in some
way at least morally and equal to two
that I'm not they're treating you for
your own good it's probably one you
haven't thought about much yeah but
that's something that you ought to think
about and so here we're not going to go
any more into the categorical imperative
we'll cover that in epics classes I'm
still here at Marist two years from now
when you take your ethics class and you
want to hear more about it directly for
me I want to come back to this now comp
talks about in the third part of the
groundwork he talks about us sort of
having two sides to ourselves there is
the sign of sensibility and heteronomy
you know other things deciding what
we're going to do desires are in
creation how things feel for us or just
a sort of moral sense he would consider
that to be hammer-ons if in fact
circulates then if in fact we are trying
to do what it is that he's sketching out
for us we're learning about a different
part of ourselves we're learning that
we're not just the sort of things that
we see smell hear experience in the
sensible world in this sensible world
you are a bag of meat and bones and
nerves but you're not just that are you
you have a Worth and a dignity because
we have a free well now can you prove
that you're actually free can you prove
that any single decision that you make
isn't because secretly deep in you know
in your heart of hearts you wanted this
or wanted that and that's something else
isn't pulling the strings con says no
you can't prove that but you have to
assume that because your world would not
make sense if you give it and again
here's how you're different than the
other animals the other animals don't
have free Wells you do and your free
will is so powerful it can even
determine itself for better or for worse
that means that there's a side of you
that is not just your inclinations and
your desires so tell me what you eat and
I don't actually know entirely who you
are tell me what you go to more broadly
tell me what you desire tell me what you
love tell me what you take Joey in I
still don't know all of you because
there's a side of you an important side
of you something that is truly who you
are that escapes all of that how do you
actually have access to it
through these sort of conceptions
through reason purifying itself of all
these other inclinations desires looking
at things universally and will
determining itself so there's a side to
you that nobody will ever be able to see
here feel anything like that but we can
know that it's there we can think that
it's there we can grasp that through
reason and I can know that you are like
me in that arsenite or that you that
both of us are like like immanuel kant's
because we have reason and and well we
have experience of what it is to make a
free decision not experience of a
worldly sense but it's something that
goes beyond so in every single human
being you're more than just what we can
see you're more than just what we could
psychoanalyze if we dug down and found
out what your deepest desires actually
are what does that look like that that's
where again I'm not a knob conscious
because unfortunately we can't say much
more about it after that point and that
part of you that that is you know free
spontaneous that can give itself rules
that can grasp things through through
reason is that individual well yes
because it's in you and it's in me but
how does yours look any different than
mine well we can't see or hear or smell
or any of those with any of them so we
can't directly compare them to each
other except through our moral life you
actually are
what you do and this is where we're
gonna we're going to leave a lot because
this is actually taking us back to
something that's kind of similar to
Aristotle you become what you do and
Aristotle is a different way of
understanding that the conduct Scott
gives you these categorical imperatives
for figuring out what you do if you want
to cultivate this side of yourself if
you work on the way that you would do it
would be through thinking about your
actions I'm thinking how you could bring
them in in line with duty so that you're
acting solely from next class we're
going to take up Kierkegaard we've got
very different